saint petersbourg en fait aujourd'hui la
ville a accueilli les célébrations de
l'anniversaire de la marine russe 325
ans le défilé qui s'est terminée en fin
de matinée on a ravi plus d'un
les plus beaux navires us est exhibée on
retrouve sur place notre correspondant
antoine frérot entendre vos jours vous
êtes donc à saint pétersbourg est la
parade est terminée oui tout à fait je
vous propose de revenir brièvement sur
le déroulé de cette matinée tout a
commencé avec l'arrivée de vladimir
poutine il a dans un premier temps salué
les différents navires qui se trouve
dernière derrière moi au niveau du
fleuve neva le fleuve qui traverse saint
pétersbourg on peut voir une frégate à
ma droite ou encore à l'écran la
corvette stoïque i qui se trouve juste
derrière moi il a ensuite débarqué
rejoint la tribune présidentielle et
s'est exprimée une courte prise de
parole à destination des marins je vous
propose d'en écouter un extrait
aujourd'hui la marine au mieux tout ce
qu'il faut pour garantir la défense de
notre patrie nos internationaux
elle est capable de découvrir tout
navire en surface ou en profondeur qui
s'approcherait de notre pays ait résisté
à tous les coups qui peuvent lui être
reporté
et c'est seulement à l'issue de ce
discours que la parade navale a pu a pu
réellement commencé alors dans un
premier temps mais en première partie
ici sur la neva au niveau de saint
pétersbourg avec le défilé d'une
vingtaine de bateaux ensuite dans
deuxième partie avait pour les bateaux
plus imposant ainsi que les sous marins
alors ce défilé a eu lieu un peu plus au
large de saint pétersbourg niveau de
l'île de cronstadt et enfin pour
terminer une troisième partie avec un
volet aérien 48 avions et hélicoptères
ont survolé la l'île de cronstadt ainsi
que la ville de saint pétersbourg à
noter également la présence de navires
étrangers des navires venant d'inde du
pakistan mais aussi de l'iran donc des
navires qui ont par qui ont parcouru
tout ce chemin jusqu'à la mer baltique
pour participer aux festivités alors
cette année cette édition marque
vous l'avez dit les 325 ans de la marine
russe la marine russe créée en voilà
tout à la toute fin du xviie siècle par
le tsar pierre le grand et merci antoine
pour toutes ces précisions